It's been four years since I first learned about the disappearance of Neyam May, an 18-year-old who went missing from the small New South Wales town of Batlow back in 2002. I don't know if it's because Neyam and I finished high school in the same year or we shared a similar taste in music, but I felt instinctively drawn to her story. As I learned more about Neyam's story, the revelations that unfolded left me in shock. The result is Missing Neyem, the latest 12-part series from Casefile Presents. Researched and hosted by me, the series features exclusive interviews with key players who help us dive into the details of Neyem's case as we go back to Batlo to try and make sense of
距离我第一次得知内亚姆·梅（Neyam May）失踪的消息已经过去四年了。2002年，这位18岁的女孩在澳大利亚新南威尔士州的一个小镇巴特洛（Batlow）失踪。我不知道是因为我和内亚姆是同一年高中毕业，还是我们有着相似的音乐品味，但我本能地被她的故事所吸引。随着我对内亚姆故事的深入了解，随之而来的真相让我感到震惊。其结果就是《寻找内亚姆》（Missing Neyem），这是Casefile Presents推出的最新12集系列节目。该系列由我负责研究和主持，包含了与关键人物的独家采访，帮助我们深入了解内亚姆案件的细节，同时我们重返巴特洛，试图弄清楚
what really happened. The entire 12-part series is available now. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early
到底发生了什么。完整的12集系列节目现已上线。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。本集节目最初作为付费订阅者的早期福利，发布在Casefile的Patreon、Apple Premium和Spotify Premium订阅源上。这些剧集旨在稍微缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些剧集
and ad free, you can support Casefile on your preferred platform. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. On Wednesday November 2, 2011, a group of anti-terrorism police officers from the Russian region of Nizhny Novgorod approached an apartment. They weren't there to make an arrest. Instead, they were visiting for research purposes. The apartment was home to a semi-famous historian whose expert opinion was being sought for a case they were working on. The officers knocked on the apartment door and were led in by the historian. Upon entering the small residence, the officers were immediately struck by its chaotic state. Every single surface, including the floor,
且无广告，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持Casefile。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。2011年11月2日星期三，来自俄罗斯下诺夫哥罗德地区的一群反恐警察接近了一间公寓。他们不是去执行逮捕任务的。相反，他们是出于调查目的进行走访。这间公寓住着一位小有名气的历史学家，警方正在为他们处理的一起案件寻求他的专家意见。警察敲了敲公寓门，历史学家将他们领了进去。进入这间狭小的住所后，警察立刻被其混乱的状态所震惊。每一个表面，包括地板，
was cluttered with enormous stacks of books, files and papers. Bags filled with what appeared to be women's and girls' clothing were strewn about. There were so many belongings scattered everywhere that officers struggled to move through the rooms without knocking things over. As they looked around at the mess, their eyes began to adjust and they could make out specific items. Dotted throughout the apartment were a number of dolls. These weren't store-bought, mass-manufactured toys, but crude, seemingly home-made and life-sized. Several were lying on the floor or across tables. Others were propped on top of dresses and wedged into nooks. The dolls were covered from head to toe, dressed in an array of mismatched old clothing.
都堆满了巨大的书籍、文件和纸张。装满看起来像是妇女和女孩衣物的袋子散落在各处。到处都是杂物，警察很难在房间里走动而不撞倒东西。当他们环顾四周的混乱时，他们的眼睛开始适应，并能辨认出具体的物品。公寓里到处散布着许多玩偶。这些不是商店购买的批量生产的玩具，而是粗糙的、看起来像是手工制作的真人大小的玩偶。有些躺在地板上或桌子上。其他的则被支撑在裙子上，塞在角落里。这些玩偶从头到脚都被遮盖着，穿着各种不匹配的旧衣服。
One wore thick stockings, a skirt and a bright pink ski jacket. Another was in what appeared to be a red tutu. A third doll wore a purple dress, stockings and a bonnet and had been positioned on a chair with its legs crossed. All of their faces were wrapped in bandages, stockings, or wax-type plaster. Some had buttons for eyes and facial features drawn on with paint or makeup, while others were left faceless. As an officer leaned in to more closely inspect one of the dolls, a shocking realisation dawned on him. Another officer reached out and touched it. Suddenly a sound filled the doll. In 1992, at the age of 20, Natalia Chardimova was expecting her first child. Natalia and her husband Igor lived in the capital of Nizhny Novgorod, the Russian city known locally as Nizhny.
一个穿着厚袜子、裙子和一件亮粉色的滑雪夹克。另一个穿着看起来像是红色芭蕾舞裙的衣服。第三个玩偶穿着紫色连衣裙、袜子和软帽，被摆放在椅子上，双腿交叉。它们所有的脸都被绷带、长筒袜或蜡质石膏包裹着。有些用纽扣做眼睛，面部特征是用颜料或化妆品画上去的，而另一些则没有脸。当一名警察凑近仔细检查其中一个玩偶时，一个令人震惊的发现浮现在他脑海中。另一名警察伸出手摸了摸它。突然，一种声音从玩偶中传出。1992年，20岁的娜塔莉亚·查迪莫娃（Natalia Chardimova）怀上了她的第一个孩子。娜塔莉亚和她的丈夫伊戈尔（Igor）住在下诺夫哥罗德的首府，这座俄罗斯城市在当地被称为下诺夫哥罗德（Nizhny）。
Located about 400 kilometres east of Moscow, Nizhny was a vibrant city with beautiful architecture, postcard scenery and a rich culture. It seemed like a good place to raise a child. That same year, Natalia and Igor welcomed their baby, a little girl who they named Olga. The couple doted on Olga and she grew into an affectionate and happy child. Olga loved expressing herself through fashion, taking particular delight in wearing dresses and accessorising her outfits with the jewellery and handbags. She often adorned her long blonde hair with bows or hair clips. The Chardimova family lived in a modest flat. Both Natalia and Igor worked day jobs, so when Olga wasn't at school she was often cared for
下诺夫哥罗德位于莫斯科以东约400公里处，是一座充满活力的城市，拥有美丽的建筑、明信片般的风景和丰富的文化。这似乎是一个抚养孩子的好地方。同年，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔迎来了他们的宝宝，一个他们取名为奥尔加（Olga）的小女孩。这对夫妇对奥尔加疼爱有加，她成长为一个充满爱心和快乐的孩子。奥尔加喜欢通过时尚来表达自己，特别喜欢穿裙子，并用珠宝和手提包来搭配她的服装。她经常用蝴蝶结或发夹装饰她那头金色的长发。查迪莫娃一家住在一间简朴的公寓里。娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔都有全职工作，所以当奥尔加不在学校时，她经常由
by her grandmother who lived close by in a neighbouring apartment block. By the spring of 2002, the now 10-year-old Olga was confident, determined, and eager for some independence. One morning, as Natalia and Igor prepared to take her to her grandmother's, Olga announced, I'm 10 already. I can go myself. Despite Olga's insistence that she was ready to make the short walk by herself, Natalia and Igor weren't keen on the
住在附近公寓楼里的祖母照顾。到了2002年春天，10岁的奥尔加已经变得自信、坚定，并渴望一些独立。一天早上，当娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔准备带她去祖母家时，奥尔加宣布：“我已经10岁了。我可以自己去。”尽管奥尔加坚持说她准备好独自走这段短路了，但娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔并不赞同这个
idea. But Olga was adamant, so reluctantly they agreed. Olga swung her favourite green handbag over her shoulder, collected her blue umbrella, and skipped out the door. It should have only taken Olga a few minutes to reach her grandmother's home, but as the minutes ticked by, she failed to show. As more time passed with no sign of the little girl, Olga's family quickly realised that something must have happened to her and called the police. Officers scoured the neighbourhood trying to find anyone who had seen the 10-year-old. They came across a local man who had a drug problem and took him in for questioning. It wasn't long before he began to talk. The man had been loitering in the foyer of
想法。但奥尔加态度坚决，所以他们勉强同意了。奥尔加把她最喜欢的绿色手提包挎在肩上，拿上她的蓝色雨伞，蹦蹦跳跳地出了门。奥尔加本应只需几分钟就能到达祖母家，但随着时间一分一秒过去，她却始终没有出现。随着时间流逝，仍不见小女孩的踪影，奥尔加的家人很快意识到她一定出了什么事，于是报了警。警察搜查了附近地区，试图寻找任何见过这个10岁女孩的人。他们遇到了一个有毒瘾的当地男子，并将他带走审问。没过多久，他就开始交代了。这名男子当时一直在
Olga's family's apartment block when he spotted the 10-year-old coming down the stairs. He moved in front of Olga, intentionally blocking her path so she couldn't exit the building. He then forced her upstairs to the top floor and demanded she hand over her earrings. He planned to sell them to a local pawn shop for some quick cash. The man told the officers that Olga had tried to run away. He didn't want her to report him, so before she could escape he grabbed a metal bar, raised it high, and brought it down hard on her head. Despite his confession, the man couldn't or wouldn't tell the police what he had done with Olga's body. Officers interrogated him endlessly and searched the apartment block and its surrounds to no avail.
奥尔加家公寓楼的门厅里徘徊，这时他看到了10岁的奥尔加走下楼梯。他走到奥尔加面前，故意挡住她的去路，让她无法离开大楼。随后，他强迫她上楼到顶层，并要求她交出耳环。他打算把耳环卖给当地的典当行换取快钱。该男子告诉警察，奥尔加曾试图逃跑。他不想让她举报自己，所以在她逃跑之前，他抓起一根金属棒，高高举起，狠狠地砸在她的头上。尽管他供认不讳，但这名男子却无法或不愿告诉警察他把奥尔加的尸体藏在了哪里。警察对他进行了无休止的审讯，并搜查了公寓楼及其周边地区，但一无所获。
Olga's parents were consumed by grief and guilt, and without Olga's body they were unable to lay her to rest. Five months went by with no further developments. Then, one day in autumn, a grisly discovery was made in the attic of the apartment block where Olga had lived. Human remains were found wedged between some pipes there. The size and structure indicated they belonged to a prepubescent girl. One side of the skull was fractured, consistent with being beaten over the head with a blunt object. skull was fractured, consistent with being beaten over the head with a blunt object. Beside the remains were a green handbag and a blue umbrella. On Wednesday October 2, 2002, Natalia and Igor buried their daughter in the Krashnaya Etna Cemetery in Nizhny's Leninsky district. They placed a temporary marker on top of her grave until
奥尔加的父母沉浸在悲痛和内疚中，由于没有奥尔加的遗体，他们无法让她入土为安。五个月过去了，没有任何进展。后来，一个秋天，在奥尔加生前居住的公寓楼阁楼里，人们有了可怕的发现。在那里的一些管道之间发现了人类遗骸。其大小和结构表明它们属于一个青春期前的女孩。头骨的一侧有骨折，这与被钝器击中头部的情况相符。遗骸旁边是一个绿色手提包和一把蓝色雨伞。2002年10月2日星期三，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔将女儿安葬在下诺夫哥罗德列宁区的克拉斯纳亚埃特纳（Krashnaya Etna）公墓。他们在她的坟墓上放置了一个临时标记，直到
the ground beneath settled and they could afford a proper headstone. Natalia and Igor visited Olga's gravesite regularly and maintained it lovingly. They laid a fresh wreath of flowers when the old one began to wilt. After about seven months, Natalia and Igor added a small metal fence around the border of the grave and painted it themselves. On Thursday May 8, 2003, the couple went to the site to finish painting the fence. As they approached Olga's grave, both were struck with an odd feeling that something wasn't right. They soon realised why. Someone had moved the wreath on Olga's grave. This interference left Natalia and Igor upset. After their next few visits proceeded with no further issues, Natalia and Igor put the incident out of their mind. But then one day,
地下的土壤沉降，他们能负担得起一块像样的墓碑。娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔经常去奥尔加的墓地，并充满爱意地维护它。当旧花圈开始枯萎时，他们会放上一束新的花圈。大约七个月后，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔在坟墓周围加了一圈小金属栅栏，并亲自给它刷了漆。2003年5月8日星期四，这对夫妇去墓地完成栅栏的粉刷工作。当他们走近奥尔加的坟墓时，两人都产生了一种奇怪的感觉，觉得有些不对劲。他们很快就明白了原因。有人移动了奥尔加坟墓上的花圈。这种干扰让娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔感到不安。在接下来的几次访问都没有出现进一步的问题后，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔便不再去想这件事。但后来有一天，
at the end of the month, they discovered something even more troubling. Someone had left a handwritten note on top of Olga's grave. It was directed at Olga, addressing her as Little Lady. The author had not left their name, instead signing off with the letters DA, meaning kind angel. Natalia and Igor were appalled. By June 2003, Natalia and Igor had finally saved enough money to buy a proper headstone. When they visited their daughter a week after it was installed, they saw something stuck to the new headstone. It was another note. This one was addressed to them. It read, If you don't erect a great monument which she deserves, we will dig her body out. Unable to afford this demand, Natalia and Eagle had no choice but to ignore it.
在月底，他们发现了更令人不安的事情。有人在奥尔加的坟墓上留下了一张手写字条。字条是写给奥尔加的，称呼她为“小淑女”。作者没有留下名字，而是用字母“DA”署名，意思是“善良的天使”。娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔感到震惊。到2003年6月，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔终于存够了钱买了一块像样的墓碑。当他们在墓碑安装一周后去探望女儿时，他们看到墓碑上粘着什么东西。那是另一张字条。这张是写给他们的。上面写着：“如果你不为她竖立她应得的伟大纪念碑，我们就会把她的尸体挖出来。”由于负担不起这个要求，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔别无选择，只能无视它。
The next time they visited Olga's grave, the headstone had been smashed to pieces. Natalia and Eagle reported the notes and the vandalised headstone to the police. The officers were sympathetic but said there was nothing they could do. Such vandalism was a common occurrence. In fact, every week in cemeteries all across the city, at least a few graves were reported as being damaged. Vandals broke headstones, stole toys and flowers, and scribbled graffiti. There had even been several reports of gravesites where the bones of those buried had been dug up and left scattered around. Nijni police occasionally patrolled the cemeteries as part of their wider city rounds, but they hadn't ever caught anyone in the act.
下一次他们去奥尔加的坟墓时，墓碑已经被砸得粉碎。娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔向警方报告了这些字条和被破坏的墓碑。警察表示同情，但说他们无能为力。这种破坏行为很常见。事实上，每周在全市各地的公墓里，至少有几座坟墓被报告遭到破坏。破坏者砸碎墓碑，偷走玩具和鲜花，并乱涂乱画。甚至还有几起报告称，坟墓里的遗骨被挖出并散落在各处。下诺夫哥罗德警方偶尔会作为全市巡逻的一部分对公墓进行巡逻，但他们从未抓到过现行犯。
Natalia and Eagle replaced the destroyed headstone with a small metal cross. It was soon bent out of shape. A few months later, in early September, Natalia and Igor discovered another note on Olga's grave. It wished Olga well for the new school year. Once again, the author had signed off as Kind Angel. The end of the school year saw another note appear which read, "'Little lady, we congratulate you on finishing the sixth grade. Keep growing as a kind, smart, pretty girl. We are very proud of you.'" Years passed and the notes continued. They were left in recognition of public holidays and other special occasions. On every New Year's Day, Natalia and Igor found stuffed toys and other decorations adorning their daughter's grave. Each time they visited the cemetery, they were fearful of what they would find.
娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔用一个小金属十字架替换了被毁坏的墓碑。它很快就被弄弯了。几个月后，在9月初，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔在奥尔加的坟墓上发现了另一张字条。它祝愿奥尔加新学年一切顺利。作者再次以“善良天使”署名。学年结束时，又出现了一张字条，上面写着：“小淑女，祝贺你完成了六年级。继续成长为一个善良、聪明、漂亮的女孩。我们为你感到非常骄傲。”几年过去了，字条还在继续出现。它们是在公共假期和其他特殊场合留下的。每个元旦，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔都会发现毛绒玩具和其他装饰品装饰着女儿的坟墓。每次去公墓，他们都害怕会发现什么。
The notes were all written as though Olga was still alive, and the harassment made it impossible for Natalia and Igor to process their grief. Over time, it put such a strain on their marriage that the two separated. Natalia moved in with her mother, while Igor remained in their apartment. He couldn't bear to leave the place that carried so many memories of Olga. In early September 2009, a homeless man was walking through a cemetery about 200 kilometres south-west of Nizhny when he encountered another man desecrating the grave of a little girl. In order to stop the vandal, he grabbed a nearby shovel and hit him across one of his hands. The vandal quickly fled. A few days later, on Saturday September 12, at a cemetery in a
这些字条写得好像奥尔加还活着一样，这种骚扰让娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔无法处理他们的悲伤。随着时间的推移，这给他们的婚姻带来了巨大的压力，以至于两人分居了。娜塔莉亚搬去和她母亲住，而伊戈尔则留在了他们的公寓里。他无法忍受离开那个承载着奥尔加许多回忆的地方。2009年9月初，一名无家可归的男子在下诺夫哥罗德西南约200公里处的一座公墓里行走时，遇到了另一名正在亵渎一个小女孩坟墓的男子。为了阻止破坏者，他抓起附近的一把铲子，击中了他的手。破坏者迅速逃离。几天后，9月12日星期六，在
neighbouring village, it was discovered that another young girl's grave had been disturbed. village, it was discovered that another young girl's grave had been disturbed. Her family had heard about the previous desecration and believed the same person must be responsible. They decided to go searching for the culprit and found a local man aged in his 50s with a hand injury. His name was Mikhail Sharov and he was promptly arrested by the police. His name was Mikhail Sharov and he was promptly arrested by the police. Upon digging into Sharov's background, the police discovered that about four months earlier he had been caught trying to exhume the bodies of young soldiers. An intoxicated Sharov, who was ex-military, had been screaming that he should be the one in the ground, not them. After that incident,
邻近村庄的一座公墓里，人们发现另一个年轻女孩的坟墓被扰动了。她的家人听说过之前的亵渎事件，认为一定是同一个人所为。他们决定去寻找罪魁祸首，并发现了一名手部受伤的50多岁当地男子。他的名字叫米哈伊尔·沙罗夫（Mikhail Sharov），他很快被警方逮捕。在深入调查沙罗夫的背景时，警方发现大约四个月前，他曾因试图挖掘年轻士兵的尸体而被抓获。醉酒的沙罗夫曾是一名军人，他当时尖叫着说，躺在地下的人应该是他，而不是他们。在那次事件之后，
Sharov was detained in a psychiatric hospital for treatment. He had only recently been released. Mikhail Sharov was found responsible for desecrating the graves of the two young girls. In February 2010, a few months after his arrest, he was once again sent for mandatory psychiatric treatment. Given his pattern of behaviour, police wondered whether Sharov might be behind more than just these two crimes. Over the last few years, there had been a troubling uptick in cemetery disturbances throughout the region, mostly involving the gravesites of young girls. Natalya and Igor Charymova had not been alone in their torment. Dozens of other families had found similar notes on their daughter's graves.
沙罗夫被送往精神病院接受治疗。他最近才被释放。米哈伊尔·沙罗夫被认定应对亵渎两名年轻女孩坟墓的行为负责。2010年2月，在他被捕几个月后，他再次被送去接受强制精神治疗。考虑到他的行为模式，警方怀疑沙罗夫可能不仅仅犯下了这两起罪行。在过去几年里，整个地区公墓的骚乱事件令人不安地增加，大多涉及年轻女孩的坟墓。娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔·查迪莫娃并不是唯一遭受折磨的人。几十个其他家庭也在他们女儿的坟墓上发现了类似的字条。
After Sharov's arrest, police compared his handwriting to these notes. It closely matched them all. handwriting to these notes. It closely matched them all. Mikhail Sharov's capture and detention didn't garner much attention. The matter was of no interest to most news outlets and was overshadowed by another event that had occurred only a week or so earlier. On the evening of Monday January 24, 2011, Moscow's Domododovvo International Airport was a buzz. Hundreds of people were greeted by loved ones as they passed through the airport arrivals hall. Then suddenly, at about 6.30pm, a man's voice cried out, I'll kill you all, before an immense explosion ripped through the crowd. 37 people were killed and nearly 100 people were injured. Hours after the blast, reports came in that amongst the wreckage, police had found the head of a 30-something man of Middle Eastern appearance.
沙罗夫被捕后，警方将他的笔迹与这些字条进行了比对。结果完全吻合。米哈伊尔·沙罗夫的被捕和拘留并没有引起太多关注。大多数新闻媒体对这件事不感兴趣，它被一周前发生的另一件事所掩盖。2011年1月24日星期一晚上，莫斯科多莫杰多沃国际机场一片喧嚣。数百人在机场到达大厅通过时受到亲人的迎接。然后突然，在晚上6点30分左右，一个男人的声音大喊：“我要杀了你们所有人！”随后，一声巨大的爆炸在人群中炸开。37人死亡，近100人受伤。爆炸发生数小时后，有报道称，在残骸中，警方发现了一个看起来像中东人的30多岁男子的头部。
Authorities announced that the man had set off a device packed with 7 kilograms of explosives. It was believed that the perpetrator belonged to a group of militant Islamists from Russia's North Caucasus region who'd orchestrated the airport attack. Only days after the bombing, several graves belonging to Muslim women were vandalised in cemeteries across Nizhnyi. Authorities were quick to assume that this was retaliation for the terrorist attack, but they noted that the nature of the vandalism was very specific. All of the targeted graves featured images of the deceased women, whether in photographs left at the site or chiselled into the headstone. Somebody had covered
当局宣布，该男子引爆了一个装有7公斤炸药的装置。据信，肇事者属于俄罗斯北高加索地区的一个激进伊斯兰组织，该组织策划了这次机场袭击。爆炸发生仅几天后，下诺夫哥罗德各地的公墓里，几座属于穆斯林妇女的坟墓遭到破坏。当局很快推测这是对恐怖袭击的报复，但他们注意到破坏行为的性质非常具体。所有被针对的坟墓都印有已故妇女的图像，无论是留在现场的照片还是刻在墓碑上的图像。有人用报纸覆盖了
the faces with newspapers and then painted over them with green paint. Black paint was smeared over their names on the graves' epitaphs. Over the next few months, more of these graves were damaged in the same way in nearly every cemetery in Nizhny. Law enforcement soon developed a different theory as to who was behind the vandalism. According to Muslim burial principles, it is forbidden to include the name or image of the deceased person on their gravestone. Perhaps some Islamic fundamentalists were attempting to strictly enforce the rules of their faith. Whoever was responsible, the escalating attacks were believed to pose a national security concern.
她们的脸，然后用绿色油漆涂抹。坟墓墓志铭上的名字也被黑色油漆涂抹。在接下来的几个月里，下诺夫哥罗德几乎所有的公墓里都有更多的坟墓以同样的方式遭到破坏。执法部门很快对谁是破坏行为的幕后黑手提出了不同的理论。根据穆斯林葬礼原则，禁止在墓碑上包含死者的名字或图像。也许一些伊斯兰原教旨主义者正试图严格执行他们的信仰规则。无论谁是幕后黑手，这些不断升级的袭击被认为构成了国家安全问题。
A special task force from the Nizhniy region's anti-terrorism unit was established to bring the situation under control. Every night, teams of officers were dispatched to patrol the city's cemeteries. Despite working the case for months, the task force couldn't make any headway. By the time more than 150 Muslim graves had been targeted, they decided it was time to consult a specialist. to specialist. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
下诺夫哥罗德地区反恐部门成立了一个特别工作组来控制局势。每天晚上，警察小组都被派往全市的公墓巡逻。尽管调查了几个月，工作组仍毫无进展。当超过150座穆斯林坟墓成为目标时，他们决定是时候咨询专家了。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. 45-year-old Anatoly Moskvin was something of a minor celebrity in Nizhny. He was a well-respected historian, lecturer and published author, and was fluent in 13 languages. Though he identified as pagan, Moskvin took an intellectual and professional interest in a broad range of faiths and religions. This underpinned Moskvin's true passion, which was the study of cemeteries and burial practices. He'd studied more than 750 cemeteries across Russia, compiling an extensive index of around 10,000 graves. Over the years, he had assisted many
感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。45岁的阿纳托利·莫斯克文（Anatoly Moskvin）在下诺夫哥罗德算是一个小有名气的人物。他是一位备受尊敬的历史学家、讲师和出版作家，精通13种语言。虽然他自认为是异教徒，但莫斯克文对广泛的信仰和宗教有着学术和专业上的兴趣。这构成了莫斯克文真正热情的基石，即对公墓和葬礼习俗的研究。他研究了俄罗斯各地超过750个公墓，编制了一份包含约10,000座坟墓的详尽索引。多年来，他协助了许多
families in searching for their ancestors. The task force believed that if anyone could provide insight into the Muslim grave desecrations, Anatoly Moskvin could. Moskvin lived in an apartment on Lennon Avenue in Nizhnyi's Leninsky district. On Wednesday November 2, 2011, officers from the Anti-Terrorism Task Force knocked on the door and were greeted by Moskvin, who invited them inside. Moskvin shared the apartment with his elderly parents, but it was difficult to see how three people could live in such a place. Every single surface, including the floor, was cluttered with books, files, papers, and bags of what appeared to be women's and girls' clothing. Amongst the mess was a number of crude and apparently homemade life-sized dolls.
家庭寻找他们的祖先。工作组认为，如果有人能对穆斯林坟墓亵渎事件提供见解，那一定是阿纳托利·莫斯克文。莫斯克文住在下诺夫哥罗德列宁区列侬大道的一间公寓里。2011年11月2日星期三，反恐工作组的警察敲开了门，受到了莫斯克文的迎接，他邀请他们进去。莫斯克文与他年迈的父母住在一起，但很难想象三个人怎么能住在这样一个地方。每一个表面，包括地板，都堆满了书籍、文件、纸张和装有看起来像是妇女和女孩衣物的袋子。在混乱中，有许多粗糙且显然是手工制作的真人大小的玩偶。
Dressed in mismatched clothing with either blank or makeup-covered masks, they were spotted on the floor, sprawled across tables, propped on top of dresses, and squeezed into corners. top of dresses and squeezed into corners. One officer leaned in for a closer inspection and realised he wasn't looking at a doll at all. It was a mummified human corpse. When another officer touched the body, the sound of a well-known children's nursery rhyme somehow began to emanate from it. The officers were nervous to handle the human dolls. Just as the first had emanated music, others would somehow speak to them upon being touched. One corpse cried out the word mum while another emitted animal growling sounds. An examination of the corpses revealed music boxes in their chest cavities. In fact,
它们穿着不匹配的衣服，戴着空白或涂满化妆品的面具，散落在地板上，横躺在桌子上，支撑在裙子上，并挤在角落里。一名警察凑近仔细检查，意识到他看到的根本不是玩偶。那是一具木乃伊化的人类尸体。当另一名警察触碰尸体时，一首著名的儿童童谣不知何故从尸体中传了出来。警察们对处理这些“人类玩偶”感到紧张。就像第一个传出音乐一样，其他的在被触碰时也会以某种方式对他们说话。一具尸体哭喊着“妈妈”这个词，而另一具则发出动物般的咆哮声。对尸体的检查显示，它们的胸腔里有音乐盒。事实上，
something had been placed in the chest cavity of nearly every corpse. Some contained random household items such as soap or a pair of tights. One had a stuffed toy heart, another held a real, dried human heart. A piece of gravestone was discovered in one human doll which gave investigators the deceased girl's name. Another contained a hospital tag with the victim's cause of death and the date she died. In total, officers discovered discovered 26 human dolls in Anatoly Moskvin's apartment and garage. Anatoly Moskvin was arrested and taken away for questioning. To investigate his surprise, he was more than willing to talk. Moskvin started by telling the officers about his first experience with the dead. When he was 12 years old,
几乎每具尸体的胸腔里都放了东西。有些装有随机的家庭用品，如肥皂或连裤袜。一个装有一个毛绒玩具心脏，另一个装有一个真实、干燥的人类心脏。在一个人类玩偶中发现了一块墓碑碎片，上面写着已故女孩的名字。另一个包含一张带有受害者死因和死亡日期的医院标签。总共，警察在阿纳托利·莫斯克文的公寓和车库里发现了26个人类玩偶。阿纳托利·莫斯克文被捕并被带走审问。令调查人员惊讶的是，他非常愿意交谈。莫斯克文首先向警察讲述了他第一次与死者接触的经历。当他12岁时，
Moskvin was participating in a waste paper collection exercise organised by his school. He and some other students were picking up papers along a street when they passed by a funeral home. Its front door was open and Moskvin could see an open casket inside. He knew whose funeral service was being held. A few days earlier, an 11-year-old girl from a neighbouring school had been electrocuted. Her name was Natasha. Moskvin recalled that all of the funeral attendees were dressed in black, holding candles and singing a mournful song in an unfamiliar language. There were only adults at the service, no children from Natasha's school. Moskvin and his peers were spotted by some of the men attending the service. For some reason, the men began to chase the children. Moskvin recalled running away in fear, but he was grabbed by one of the men and
莫斯克文正在参加学校组织的废纸回收活动。他和一些其他学生在街上捡纸时，经过了一家殡仪馆。它的前门开着，莫斯克文可以看到里面有一口敞开的棺材。他知道是谁的葬礼。几天前，邻近学校的一名11岁女孩触电身亡。她的名字叫娜塔莎（Natasha）。莫斯克文回忆说，所有的葬礼参加者都穿着黑衣服，拿着蜡烛，用一种不熟悉的语言唱着哀伤的歌。仪式上只有成年人，没有娜塔莎学校的孩子。莫斯克文和他的同伴被参加仪式的一些男人发现了。出于某种原因，这些男人开始追赶孩子们。莫斯克文回忆说，他惊恐地逃跑，但被其中一个男人抓住，并
dragged inside the funeral home. A woman stepped forward. She was in tears and holding a large apple. Moskvin assumed she was Natasha's mother. The woman handed Moskvin the apple and pushed him toward the open casket. When Moskvin was standing right beside Natasha's body, the woman told him to kiss Natasha on the forehead. Moskvin refused and started to cry. Someone put their hand on the back of his head and pushed down. He felt he had no choice but to kiss the dead Natasha. He was made to do this three times. Moskvin was then handed two copper rings. He was instructed to place one on Natasha's finger and one on his own while repeating an old Russian phrase. Moskvin was then escorted, along with all of the others, to the cemetery. There he watched as they lowered Natasha's coffin into the ground.
被拖进了殡仪馆。一个女人走上前来。她泪流满面，手里拿着一个大苹果。莫斯克文以为她是娜塔莎的母亲。女人把苹果递给莫斯克文，把他推向敞开的棺材。当莫斯克文站在娜塔莎的尸体旁边时，女人让他亲吻娜塔莎的额头。莫斯克文拒绝了，并开始哭泣。有人把手放在他的后脑勺上，用力向下推。他觉得别无选择，只能亲吻死去的娜塔莎。他被迫这样做了三次。随后，莫斯克文被递给两枚铜戒指。他被指示把一枚戴在娜塔莎的手指上，另一枚戴在自己的手指上，同时重复一句古老的俄语短语。莫斯克文随后和其他所有人一起被护送到公墓。在那里，他看着他们把娜塔莎的棺材降入地下。
Natasha's mother threw some dirt on top of the coffin and motioned for Moskvin to do the same. After the burial, they handed him some fruit and a little bit of cash. As soon as they let go of him, Moskvin ran. Moskvin threw the fruit away but bought some books with the money. While he didn't understand exactly what had happened, he couldn't shake the feeling that Natasha's funeral had also been a wedding. been a wedding. That childhood experience sparked Anatoly Moskvin's lifelong fascination with burials and funeral rites. It was during his later studies of this subject that he learnt of several cultures that practiced the art of resurrecting the dead. Moskvin insisted that his interest in the deceased girls was in no way sexual. It was paternal.
娜塔莎的母亲在棺材上撒了一些土，并示意莫斯克文也这样做。葬礼结束后，他们给了他一些水果和一点现金。他们一放开他，莫斯克文就跑了。莫斯克文把水果扔掉了，但用钱买了一些书。虽然他不完全明白发生了什么，但他无法摆脱一种感觉，即娜塔莎的葬礼也是一场婚礼。那次童年经历激发了阿纳托利·莫斯克文对葬礼和丧葬仪式的终身迷恋。正是在后来研究这一主题时，他了解到有几种文化实行复活死者的艺术。莫斯克文坚称，他对已故女孩的兴趣绝非性方面的。它是父爱般的。
For a long time, Moskvin had wanted to become a father. He told officers that nearly 10 years earlier in 2003 he had applied to adopt a girl from a local orphanage. Neither of his parents had supported his application and the assessors, finding that Moskvin was too financially unstable, rejected his application. Upon learning of his rejection, Moskvin grew upset. He decided to calm his nerves by taking a walk through one of his favourite cemeteries, Krashnaya Retna. During his stroll, he noticed the unassuming grave of a ten-year-old girl, adorned with a wreath of flowers and framed by a small metal fence. At that moment, he made a decision. The following night of Friday May 9, Moskvin returned to the girl's grave.
很长一段时间以来，莫斯克文一直想成为一名父亲。他告诉警察，大约10年前的2003年，他曾申请领养当地一家孤儿院的女孩。他的父母都不支持他的申请，而评估人员发现莫斯克文的经济状况太不稳定，拒绝了他的申请。得知被拒绝后，莫斯克文感到很沮丧。他决定通过在他最喜欢的公墓之一——克拉斯纳亚埃特纳（Krashnaya Retna）散步来平复心情。在散步时，他注意到了一个十岁女孩不起眼的坟墓，上面装饰着花圈，并围着一圈小金属栅栏。那一刻，他做出了一个决定。第二天晚上，即5月9日星期五，莫斯克文回到了女孩的坟墓。
Using a chisel, he began carefully clearing away the dirt on the top of the grave. After some time, he reached the coffin. He dug the chisel into the wood of the coffin's lid and began to create a large hole. He reached down into the coffin and dragged the girl's body out through the hole. Her corpse was already substantially decomposed and covered in maggots. Moskvin brushed them off to better see her burial outfit. She was wearing a white blouse and a black skirt with tights and shoes. Her long blonde hair was still intact. Moskvin swept all of the dirt back on top of the coffin so that the grave looked undisturbed.
他用凿子开始小心地清理坟墓顶部的泥土。过了一会儿，他到达了棺材。他把凿子插进棺材盖的木头里，开始凿出一个大洞。他伸手进棺材，把女孩的尸体从洞里拖了出来。她的尸体已经严重腐烂，布满了蛆虫。莫斯克文把它们刷掉，以便更好地观察她的葬礼服装。她穿着一件白色衬衫和一条黑色裙子，配着连裤袜和鞋子。她那头金色的长发依然完好无损。莫斯克文把所有的泥土扫回棺材上，使坟墓看起来没有被动过。
He then carefully wrapped the girls' remains and hid them in a different part of the cemetery. Moskvin returned home and began to create a workshop space in his building's basement. Days later, he went back to the cemetery to retrieve the girl's body and took her home. There, he mixed together a specific combination of soda and salt, then placed the girl's remains in the mix. His goal was to dry the corpse out. His goal was to dry the corpse out. It took months for the process to be complete. When it was done, Moskvin wrapped the girl's face and hands and dressed her in some second-hand clothes. Finally, he painted on some facial features. Moskvin had his first doll. It was Olga charting over. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
然后，他小心地包裹好女孩的遗骸，并将它们藏在公墓的另一个地方。莫斯克文回到家，开始在他大楼的地下室里建立一个工作室空间。几天后，他回到公墓取回女孩的尸体，并把她带回家。在那里，他混合了一种特定的苏打和盐的组合，然后把女孩的遗骸放在混合物中。他的目标是把尸体弄干。这个过程花了几个月才完成。完成后，莫斯克文包裹了女孩的脸和手，并给她穿上了一些二手衣服。最后，他画上了一些面部特征。莫斯克文有了他的第一个玩偶。那是奥尔加·查迪莫娃。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. From that moment on, Anatoly Moskvin was determined to make more dolls. He watched the local news closely and scoured the internet, searching for reports of young girls who had been killed or died in accidents. When he came across a potential candidate, he noted the date she was due to be buried and in witch cemetery. At night he would visit her grave, often sleeping on top of the fresh dirt for hours. He said that if he felt good intentions emanating from the child's spirit, he would dig her up and mummify her. Many of the girls were orphans.
感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。从那一刻起，阿纳托利·莫斯克文决心制作更多的玩偶。他密切关注当地新闻，并搜寻互联网，寻找关于被杀或死于事故的年轻女孩的报道。当他遇到一个潜在的候选人时，他会记下她预定埋葬的日期和所在的公墓。晚上，他会去她的坟墓，经常在新鲜的泥土上睡上几个小时。他说，如果他感觉到女孩灵魂中散发出良好的意图，他就会把她挖出来并制成木乃伊。许多女孩是孤儿。
Moskvin journaled extensively about each of his cemetery visits and the subsequent mummification process. In the intervening periods, he would exhume women's graves to steal clothes from the corpses. He took the garments home and washed them so he could dress each new doll in a special outfit. Moskvin told police officers that he considered all of his dolls to be his daughters. He read to them, sang to them, and set them all up in the living area so they could watch cartoons together. Moskvin said that he and his dolls had their own language and celebrated their own
莫斯克文详细记录了他每次去公墓的经历以及随后的木乃伊化过程。在间隔期间，他会挖掘妇女的坟墓，从尸体上偷衣服。他把衣服带回家洗干净，这样他就可以给每个新玩偶穿上一套特别的衣服。莫斯克文告诉警察，他认为他所有的玩偶都是他的女儿。他给她们读书，给她们唱歌，并把她们都摆在起居区，这样她们就可以一起看动画片。莫斯克文说，他和他的玩偶有他们自己的语言，并庆祝他们自己的
holidays. Their spirits communicated with him. Moskvin had his favourites which were kept in his bedroom. If he lost interest in a particular doll he would move her to the garage. Sometimes he grew to dislike certain dolls so much that he returned them to their graves. The 26 corpses that the officers found in their search had only been his current cohort. In the last nine years, Moskvin had exhumed and mummified the bodies of more than 80 young girls. The youngest and most recently acquired corpse belonged to a two-year-old girl who Moskvin called Masher. Just a few months earlier in the summer, Masher had been on a road trip to Crimea with her family for a seaside vacation. About halfway into the journey, a driver in another vehicle made an
节日。她们的灵魂与他交流。莫斯克文有他的最爱，她们被放在他的卧室里。如果他对某个特定的玩偶失去了兴趣，他会把她移到车库。有时他变得非常不喜欢某些玩偶，以至于他把她们送回了她们的坟墓。警察在搜查中发现的26具尸体只是他目前的“群体”。在过去的九年里，莫斯克文挖掘并木乃伊化了80多名年轻女孩的尸体。最年轻且最近获得的尸体属于一个两岁的小女孩，莫斯克文叫她玛莎（Masha）。就在几个月前的夏天，玛莎曾和家人一起去克里米亚进行海滨度假。在旅程中途，另一辆车里的司机做了一个
illegal maneuver and crashed into Masher's family's car. Masha's older brother sustained a severe laceration to his stomach but survived. Masha and her parents died instantly. Soon after the accident, the family were buried in a cemetery in the northwest of Nizhny. A few months later, in early October, Moskvin dug up Masha's grave. He was especially interested in what clothes she had been buried in. After he pulled Masha's remains out of the coffin, he saw that she was wearing an elaborate white dress. Moskvin told officers that he was disappointed to find the upper half of Masha's body had already begun to decompose, which was not suitable for his purposes. Masha's lower half, however, was still intact.
违规动作，撞上了玛莎家人的车。玛莎的哥哥腹部受了重伤，但幸存了下来。玛莎和她的父母当场死亡。事故发生后不久，这家人被埋葬在下诺夫哥罗德西北部的一个公墓里。几个月后，在10月初，莫斯克文挖开了玛莎的坟墓。他特别感兴趣的是她被埋葬时穿的衣服。在他把玛莎的遗骸从棺材里拉出来后，他看到她穿着一件精致的白色连衣裙。莫斯克文告诉警察，他很失望地发现玛莎尸体的上半部分已经开始腐烂，这不适合他的目的。然而，玛莎的下半部分依然完好无损。
Moskvin bisected Masha's corpse. He wrapped her upper body in a rag and reburied it carelessly, leaving some of her bones strewn around her grave. He placed Masha's lower half and her burial gown in a bag and took them home. After Moskvin mummified Masha's partial remains, he attached them to the head and torso of an actual porcelain doll. He then redressed the hybrid doll in Masha's white burial gown. He then redressed the hybrid doll in Masha's white burial gown. It wasn't the first time he'd done that. Once he had even sewn a teddy bear's head on top of a homemade doll. Moskvin told officers that he was waiting for science to catch up with his work.
莫斯克文将玛莎的尸体一分为二。他用一块破布包裹住她的上半身，并草率地重新埋葬，留下她的一些骨头散落在坟墓周围。他把玛莎的下半身和她的葬礼服放在一个袋子里，带回了家。莫斯克文将玛莎的部分遗骸制成木乃伊后，将它们连接到一个真正的瓷娃娃的头部和躯干上。然后，他给这个混合玩偶重新穿上了玛莎的白色葬礼服。这已经不是他第一次这样做了。有一次，他甚至把一个泰迪熊的头缝在一个自制玩偶的顶部。莫斯克文告诉警察，他正在等待科学赶上他的工作。
He believed one day it would advance to a point that his dolls could actually be resurrected and brought to life. Anatoli Moskvin was charged with multiple counts of desecrating human remains and their burial sites. He was held in custody pending trial while officers commenced the difficult task of contacting his victims' families. Despite being constantly tormented by the notes left on their daughter's grave, Olga Chardimova's parents, Natalia and Igor, had managed to rebuild their lives. After 14 months of separation, the couple rekindled their marriage. In 2009, Natalia gave birth to their second child, a son they named Alexei.
他相信有一天科学会进步到他的玩偶可以真正复活并被带回生活的地步。阿纳托利·莫斯克文被控多项亵渎人类遗骸及其埋葬地点的罪名。他在等待审判期间被拘留，同时警察开始了联系受害者家属的艰巨任务。尽管不断受到留在女儿坟墓上的字条的折磨，奥尔加·查迪莫娃的父母，娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔，还是设法重建了他们的生活。在分居14个月后，这对夫妇重燃了他们的婚姻。2009年，娜塔莉亚生下了他们的第二个孩子，一个他们取名为阿列克谢（Alexei）的儿子。
Natalia felt that her faith in life had been restored. When Natalia and Igor were informed of Moskvin's capture and what he had done to Olga's remains, they were horrified. Natalia later told reporters, They were horrified. Natalia later told reporters, My girl had been murdered. If anyone deserved to rest in peace, she did. But instead, her grave has been robbed. The police strongly advised the couple not to view the doll that Moskvin had created from Olga's remains. They told Natalia and Igor that the site was too grotesque. To ensure the investigation was as thorough as possible, police obtained Natalia and Igor's permission to exhume Olga's grave. On Friday October 5, 2012, 11 months after Moskvin's arrest,
娜塔莉亚觉得她对生活的信念已经恢复。当娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔被告知莫斯克文被捕以及他对奥尔加遗骸所做的事情时，他们感到非常恐惧。娜塔莉亚后来告诉记者：“我的女孩被谋杀了。如果有人应该安息，那一定是她。但相反，她的坟墓被抢劫了。”警方强烈建议这对夫妇不要看莫斯克文用奥尔加遗骸制作的玩偶。他们告诉娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔，那个场景太可怕了。为了确保调查尽可能彻底，警方获得了娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔的许可，挖掘了奥尔加的坟墓。2012年10月5日星期五，在莫斯克文被捕11个月后，
Natalia and Igor watched as Olga's coffin was raised from the ground. There was a large hole in the lid at the head of the coffin, exactly as Moskvin had described. Inside, the coffin was empty. Overcome with shock and grief, Natalia nearly collapsed. Moskvin had exhumed Olga's remains the night after Natalia and Igor noticed that a wreath they'd left had been moved. Every time they visited Olga's grave thereafter, her coffin had been empty. Natalia told reporters,
娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔看着奥尔加的棺材从地下升起。棺材盖的头部有一个大洞，正如莫斯克文所描述的那样。里面，棺材是空的。被震惊和悲伤所淹没，娜塔莉亚几乎晕倒。莫斯克文在娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔注意到他们留下的花圈被移动后的那天晚上，挖掘了奥尔加的遗骸。此后他们每次去奥尔加的坟墓，她的棺材都是空的。娜塔莉亚告诉记者：
I still find it hard to grasp the scale of his sickening work, but for nine years he was living with my mummified daughter in his bedroom. I had her for ten years. He had her for nine. After Moskvin's arrest, his parents were interviewed by police. They said that they'd never noticed a foul smell inside the apartment and had no idea that the dolls were actually human bodies. They'd just thought their son had a strange but harmless hobby. For around six months each year, they left the city to stay in their country house. They had no idea what he got up to while they were away.
“我仍然觉得很难理解他那令人作呕的工作规模，但九年来，他一直和木乃伊化的女儿住在他的卧室里。我拥有她十年。他拥有她九年。”莫斯克文被捕后，他的父母接受了警察的采访。他们说，他们从未注意到公寓里有难闻的气味，也不知道这些玩偶实际上是人类尸体。他们只是认为他们的儿子有一个奇怪但无害的爱好。每年大约有六个月，他们离开城市去乡下的房子住。他们根本不知道他在他们离开时做了什么。
During Moskvin's extensive interviews he admitted to much more than the creation of his dolls. He explained that he was also responsible for desecrating the graves of Muslim women around the city. These crimes had nothing to do with the airport bomb attack. Instead, Moskvin was angry about a civil claim he'd brought against one of the representatives of the local Muslim community. After the court ruled against him, Moskvin began vandalising the graves in retaliation. Moskvin expressed no regret or remorse for any of his actions except in one instance. His former cellmate came forward to give an exclusive interview to the newspaper Moskovsky Komsomolets and said that Moskvin had admitted to feeling guilty about Mikhail Sharov. Sharv was the man who had been
在莫斯克文的详尽审讯中，他承认的罪行远不止制作玩偶。他解释说，他还负责亵渎了该市周围穆斯林妇女的坟墓。这些罪行与机场炸弹袭击无关。相反，莫斯克文是因为他针对当地穆斯林社区的一位代表提起的民事诉讼败诉而感到愤怒。在法院判决他败诉后，莫斯克文开始破坏坟墓以示报复。除了一个例子外，莫斯克文对自己的任何行为都没有表现出遗憾或悔恨。他以前的狱友站出来接受了《莫斯科共青团员报》的独家采访，称莫斯克文承认对米哈伊尔·沙罗夫感到内疚。沙罗夫是那个被
found responsible for digging up the graves of two young girls in neighbouring towns about 200 kilometres outside of Nizhny. While in custody, Moskvin confessed to his cellmate that he'd actually committed those crimes. By the time Moskvin was arrested, Shirov had already been released from psychiatric treatment. But according to Moskvin's former cellmate, Moskvin still seemed haunted by the injustice. Anatoly Moskvin stood trial on Wednesday February 27, 2013. During his time in custody, Moskvin was thoroughly assessed by psychologists and psychiatrists. According to their findings, Moskvin suffered from paranoid schizophrenia. The court found that Anatoly Moskvin's mental disorder impaired his ability to understand
认定负责挖掘下诺夫哥罗德外约200公里处邻近城镇两名年轻女孩坟墓的人。在拘留期间，莫斯克文向他的狱友坦白，实际上是他犯下了那些罪行。当莫斯克文被捕时，沙罗夫已经结束了精神治疗被释放。但据莫斯克文的前狱友说，莫斯克文似乎仍然被这种不公正所困扰。阿纳托利·莫斯克文于2013年2月27日星期三受审。在拘留期间，莫斯克文接受了心理学家和精神病医生的全面评估。根据他们的调查结果，莫斯克文患有偏执型精神分裂症。法院认定，阿纳托利·莫斯克文的精神障碍损害了他理解
the nature and social impact of his actions. Moskvin knew what he'd done was illegal, but he didn't believe it was wrong. He maintained this conviction throughout, even telling the girls' family members who were present in the courtroom, quote, "...you abandoned your girls in the cold. I brought them home and warmed them up. The court found Moskvin was not criminally responsible for his actions and ordered that
其行为的性质和社会影响的能力。莫斯克文知道自己的所作所为是非法的，但他并不认为这是错误的。他始终坚持这一信念，甚至对在法庭上的女孩家属说：“……你们把女孩丢在寒冷中。我把她们带回家，给她们温暖。”法院认定莫斯克文对其行为不负刑事责任，并下令
he be subjected to compulsory medical measures in a secure psychiatric facility until such time as he no longer posed a threat to others. as he no longer posed a threat to others. Moskvin's compulsory treatment was reassessed every six months. Each time, the measures were extended. Over the years, the chief physician at the facility in which Moskvin was being held petitioned the court for Moskvin to be declared incompetent. Such a classification would allow Moskvin to be placed in home care or an open facility, rather than being permanently locked up. Moskvin would still continue treatment and supervision, but would be allowed to move about the city freely. On Tuesday August 2, 2022, after nearly 10 years in secure custody, the District Court approved
他必须在安全的精神病院接受强制医疗，直到他不再对他人构成威胁。莫斯克文的强制治疗每六个月重新评估一次。每次，措施都会延长。多年来，莫斯克文被关押机构的首席医生向法院请愿，要求宣布莫斯克文无行为能力。这种分类将允许莫斯克文被安置在家庭护理或开放式设施中，而不是被永久关押。莫斯克文仍将继续接受治疗和监督，但将被允许在城市中自由活动。2022年8月2日星期二，在被安全拘留近10年后，地方法院批准了
the petition and Moskvin was reclassified. However, as of the date of this recording, Moskvin has not been moved to home care and his treatment in a secure facility continues. Natalia Charimova has shared concern about Moskvin's potential release, stating, I worry that one day he will convince them he's sane and he'll come out and start his morbid activities again. This concern is heightened by a remark Moskvin made to police as they removed the corpses from his home. Quote, Don't bury them too deep, because the moment I get out, I'm going to come back for them. All that Natalia and Igor want is for their daughter to finally rest in peace. They have reburied Olga's remains in an unmarked grave in an undisclosed location. When 18-year-old Nea May went missing in 2002, her family did everything they could to help
该请愿书，莫斯克文被重新分类。然而，截至本录音之日，莫斯克文尚未被转移到家庭护理，他在安全设施中的治疗仍在继续。娜塔莉亚·查里莫娃对莫斯克文可能获释表示担忧，她说：“我担心有一天他会说服他们他神志正常，然后他会出来并再次开始他病态的活动。”当警察从他家中移走尸体时，莫斯克文对警察说的一句话加剧了这种担忧。他说：“别把她们埋得太深，因为我一出来，就会回来找她们。”娜塔莉亚和伊戈尔所希望的只是让他们的女儿最终安息。他们已将奥尔加的遗体重新安葬在未公开地点的无名墓中。当18岁的尼娅·梅在2002年失踪时，她的家人尽其所能帮助
the police find her. But like so many missing persons cases, there comes a time when the leads dry up and there's nowhere left to look. At no point have we just got on with our lives. I heard something recently that really resonated. It was a woman from America who said that you never get over grief. You learn to move forward with it and I was like that's the best anyone's ever described it. Niamh's sister, Fannula, realised that a podcast might help find the answers the family was looking for. So for the past four years,
警方找到她。但像许多失踪人员案件一样，总会有一个线索枯竭、无处可寻的时候。我们从未停止过生活。我最近听到了一些真正引起共鸣的话。那是一位来自美国的女性，她说你永远无法克服悲伤。你学会带着它继续前进，我想这就是对它最好的描述。尼娅的妹妹法努拉意识到，播客可能有助于找到家人正在寻找的答案。因此，在过去的四年里，
I've been working with Nehems family to take a closer look at the case. And what we found took us to places we never anticipated. Here's everything we've done. We've obviously got serious concerns about her welfare. I've just spoken to the last person to see her alive that we knew about, and he's given me a bullshit story. When I first started looking into this case in 2020 it was originally intended to be a single
我一直与尼娅的家人合作，更仔细地审视这个案件。我们发现的事情把我们带到了我们从未预料到的地方。这是我们所做的一切。我们显然对她的安危有严重的担忧。我刚刚和我们所知的最后一个见到她活着的人谈过，他给了我一个胡说八道的故事。当我2020年第一次开始调查这个案件时，它最初打算成为一个单一的
case file episode but the more I looked the more I found. So Steve, he's adamant that she never made it to Go Cup Road. Stan is adamant that there's a credible sighting there. Niamh set out for a gap year after finishing high school to test her independence, but she never made it home. What happened in those final days? And when the Blackhurst arrived, these two men got out, and as soon as I saw them and I saw that Blackhurst, I thought, their baddies stay away from them. Mum called me and she said, look, the police are investigating now
案件档案剧集，但我看得越多，发现的就越多。所以史蒂夫坚持认为她从未到达戈卡普路。斯坦坚持认为那里有一个可信的目击点。尼娅在高中毕业后开始了一年的间隔年以测试她的独立性，但她从未回家。最后几天发生了什么？当那辆黑色赫斯特车到达时，这两个人下来了，我一看到他们和那辆黑色赫斯特车，我就想，他们是坏人，离他们远点。妈妈给我打电话说，看，警察现在正在调查
and somebody claims that they dropped her off and she was hitchhiking. What started out as a potential case file episode turned into a 12-part series that took over four years to research. He didn't smile or anything. He just kind of looked empty and just like get in the car. It was just kind of like aggressively like get in the car. Join me as we uncover
有人声称他们让她下车，她当时正在搭便车。最初可能是一个案件档案剧集的内容变成了一个12集的系列节目，花费了四年多的时间进行研究。他没有笑或什么的。他只是看起来很空洞，就像‘上车’。这就像是一种侵略性的‘上车’。加入我，让我们揭开
what happened in Missing Nehiem, the new 12-part podcast series from Casefile Presents. Something had obviously woken me suddenly because I was disorientated. That's when I realised that there was just a cold, rough hand holding my hand, because I had my hand over the edge of the bed. And I could see the outline of somebody leaning over the bed. Eva, I guess, has to be somewhat attractive, doesn't it? Otherwise, I wouldn't be able to sneak into every corner.
《寻找尼娅》中发生了什么，这是来自Casefile Presents的全新12集播客系列。显然有什么东西突然把我吵醒了，因为我感到迷失方向。就在那时，我意识到有一只冰冷、粗糙的手握着我的手，因为我的手放在床边。我可以看到有人弯腰靠在床上的轮廓。伊娃，我想，必须要有一定的吸引力，对吧？否则，我就无法潜入每一个角落。
So I whispered to my sister, asked her if she was awake, and she said yes. I said, there's someone in the room, and she said, I know. Missing Nehem is available now. Be sure to download and follow Missing Nehem wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我低声问我妹妹她是否醒着，她说是的。我说，房间里有人，她说，我知道。《寻找尼娅》现已上线。请务必下载并关注《寻找尼娅》，无论您在哪里收听播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。